a few stories came out one of them is
nato ship so let's go through the one
with nato ships on page five uh nato
sends ships
fighter jets to eastern europe as russia
tensions uh simmer this a political
story nato announced on monday that
european allies were deploying added
ships and fighter jets to eastern europe
and putting new forces on standby in
response to russia's continued military
mobilization along the ukrainian border
nato's announcement comes amid reports
that senior pentagon officials on
saturday presented u.s president biden
with options for adopting a more
aggressive posture towards russia that
would include deploying additional
military forces and equipment to eastern
europe while ukraine is not an ally nato
countries have threatened severe
sanctions in response to any attack and
secretary general jens uh stalsenberg
has said that the alliance will move
quickly and forcefully to protect its
members including the small baltic
nations under article five the
collective defense clause in the nato
treaty how concerned are you with what's
going on over there right now i mean
it's obviously alarming and i would just
point out like
it's remarkable how
russia annexed part of ukraine crimean
peninsula under obama biden was vice
president he was the point guy on
ukraine he visited 17 times i think
during um his vice presidency then trump
gets into office then for four years
we didn't have any more incursions into
ukraine putin was not pushing i mean
they kept the crimea but they weren't
like trying to gain more ground
now suddenly a year after biden takes
office
putin is back
and he is i mean by all accounts like he
is serious he does want to make this um
incursion whether it's like a
conventional invasion i don't know but
there are other things that can be done
that are acts of war like hybrid war
sending it like they did with crimea
like unmarked troops basically um cyber
attacks like different types of things
they can do to ukraine and so the
question is like why does the aggression
surge under
obama and biden but not under trump you
know and i think you know one of those
three presidents was called a russian
agent so i think it just absurd when you
look at it the the two presidents where
russia has gained power were both
democrats right and like um trump the
one that they they made up all these
russia stories about
was was one where during his presidency
ukraine was in a safer position by far
than it is now now going to nato i mean
um so nato it's interesting because what
trump said about nato when he was first
running for president was that they need
to pay their fair share there are a lot
of countries in nato that do not pay the
2 percent of the gdp towards defense
which is required
by the alliance and
he was right frankly we see germany for
example they don't pay that two percent
and they rely on russia for natural gas
for their population so it's like they
have a lot of dealings with russia that
makes them unable to or unwilling to
come to the defense of an ally ukraine
is not a nato ally though so like if
russia invades ukraine it doesn't
trigger that article 5 which is like
means collective defense that all the
nato allies have to come to their
defense it doesn't mean that nobody will
it just means it's not required um by
the treaty
yeah another daily wire came out saying
biden slammed over reports he can't
evacuate u.s citizens out of ukraine
criminally incompetent news reports
indicate that the bible administration
has ordered families of all american
personnel u.s embassy in ukraine to
immediately the country has warned u.s
citizen the country that will be unable
to evacuate and it's considering sending
u.s military forces to eastern europe
given that the president has said
military actions by russia could come
out at any time the u.s government will
not be in position to evacuate u.s
citizens biden state department said so
and so u.s citizens currently present
any in ukraine should plan accordingly
what does this really mean because the
continue to say monica crowley former
trump official says biden here is still
cool with abandoning americans and war
zones holy crap it's august all over
again i mean frankly that was my first
reaction when i saw this too because we
all remember what happened in
afghanistan this horrible tragedy that
happened a few months ago in summer
when americans were stranded when
hundreds i mean we don't even know how
many afghans civilians were killed at
that airport bombing we lost 13 american
service members at that bombing and so
these images and what we saw there
during this botched and just horrific
withdrawal from afghanistan that was
botched in every way um this is all it's
fresh in our minds so when we hear the
same types of rhetoric coming out like
that americans need to leave you can
arrange your own transportation out of
ukraine that does bring back deja vu it
brings back that very traumatic memory
recently of what happened in afghanistan
and you know i i truly hope like ukraine
is different for afghanistan i truly
hope we don't see a repeat um of what we
saw over there but it is worrisome that
it seems like biden has left putin in
the driver's seat so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]